you know most people i know have seen
death note but most people i would wager
don't actually know what death note
really is about so it's a show about
pizza despite the original manga only
running for about two and a half years
in weekly shonen jump the series has
since its debut in 2003 sold over 30
million copies on just three volumes
alone spawning a wildly popular anime
adaptation for live-action films two of
which are based on completely original
material a j-drama multiple video games
multiple stage plays and musicals and
even regrettably an american remake film
produced by netflix critically it
remains one of the most highly acclaimed
and off-discussed manga in circulation
to this day though interestingly this
seems to primarily be maintained in the
west while in japan the manga's
notoriety has waned enough to where it
didn't even show up in the top 100 when
tvsi surveyed japanese readers in late
2020 while using the phrase monolithic
would generally come off as arrogant
it's difficult to describe death note as
anything else while most of the series
that jump publishes even the titanically
popular ones like dragon ball and one
piece exist as entities within jump's
collective branded canon death note
exists almost entirely as an entity unto
itself separate from it all heck the
mere mention of a notebook that causes
death is something which acts as a
reference to the franchise with
countless parodies and homages that have
sprouted from it over the years even
actual literal real-life murders have
been committed in tribute to this very
franchise and while screwed up on so
many levels it only further speaks to
the iconography the story itself
possesses as a piece of literary canon
it is however this public discussion
that i feel like something has been lost
not just in so far as the back and forth
on various specificities regarding its
story but even the central ideas on the
manga itself have been lost i believe
pressed under a mountain of adaptation
and misinterpretation to where the
original meaning has been almost
entirely lost for this analysis i think
it's worth looking back at the original
work and consequently asking a simple
question
what exactly is death note really about
death notes to mangaka writer tsugumi
oba and artist takeshi obata are two men
with interesting personal histories to
say the least while it has never been
confirmed by a direct source a popular
rumor about tsugumi oba is that he is
and always has been nothing but a
pseudonym for gag mangaka hiroshi gammo
gamo's work was very much a prototypical
jump gag series of the time dense in
absurdism in wordplay and geared heavily
to jump's child audience while this did
make him something of a favorite amongst
jumps offices demonstrated in a mostly
cafe feud he had with competing gag
manga arthur yasui kita that saw keita
end his own series outright blaming gamu
for his inability to get off the ground
the well dried up and after two
attempted runs in 1998 and then 2000
failed to garner publicity gamu more or
less vanished from the public eye
entirely obata on the other hand is a
bit of a different story achieving the
much vaunted tetsuka prize in 1985 and
performing his first formal
serialization cyborg grandpa ji when he
was just 20 years of age mobata had
gained a reputation as a budding talent
over a series of collaborations in the
90s before hitting it big in 1998 when
he together with yumi hota created
hikaru no go the series was a runaway
success spawning a resurgence in goa as
a game and lasted to mid 2003 just a few
months before death note debuted the
reason i bring these two backstories up
is to offer a point of contextualization
on the series as a whole death note is
not the work of some young author coming
in to jump to shake things up with a
bowl new vision but a collaboration of a
40 year old washout under a false
identity and a superstar artist still
writing his fame working together under
prior relationships they had within jump
itself looking at the timeline of the
end of ikaru the one shot's publication
and the official serialization of the
manga itself it becomes clear that death
note has been essentially primed in a
pipeline from the start with the one
shot itself just meant to gauge audience
reception and establish the false
identity of oba to the public its
artistic deviations from jumps norm are
not a visionary working against a
hierarchy but instead a hierarchy
purposely deviating from itself for
revenue and this is all to say that a
common statement made about death note
insofar as its relationship to jump is
that it doesn't fit in with the rest of
jumps publications and on a surface
level observation looking at what was
being published at the time this is
correct at a time where jump was
primarily embracing bright fanciful
narratives full of youthful boyish
optimism death note is harshly cynical
decidedly grounded in its scope and
operates less on dramatic climaxes as
much as meticulous buildup and
articulation of its cast only about a
dozen are given substantial page time or
focus of any kind and even then the
manga with one exception notably avoids
dedicating substantial flashbacks to
explaining character backstories and
motivations instead choosing to center
the story squarely around a singular
serialized narrative without any breaks
of any kind this was compounded of
course by light himself not just in the
obvious fact that he is a literal mass
murderer but light in many ways was not
someone jumps target reader base was set
to relate to unlike the scrappy outcast
and delinquents who defined protagonists
in the publication for the last 15 years
light is a top level student set for the
best university in the country beloved
by his peers popular with women and is
the son of a deputy director of the
japanese npa he is not someone to be
associated with but an archetype of
ideal japanese youth and the manga
crucially uses that as shorthand for his
entire characterization that feeds into
every aspect of his personality and
actions what especially sticks out about
this is when one reads death note's
original one shot pilot the pilot while
it retains much of the bases insofar as
the idea of the death note and shinigami
including the character of ryuk it is
otherwise radically different and in a
way that makes it far closer to a
typical jump manga the one shot's
protagonist taro kagame is an ordinary
13 year old kid who after accidentally
killing his bullies with the death note
is utterly horrified by the deaths he's
caused to the point of being unable to
sleep he refuses to use a death note
after understanding his true purpose
tries to actively cooperate with the
police and goes out of his way to stop
his best friend from using the notebook
even at risk of his own life
everything that light is not
what is most striking however is the
inclusion of a single plot point that
radically goes against everything in the
actual series the death eraser using an
eraser provided by ryuk taro is able to
erase the lines of text written in the
notebook and undo the debts it has
caused the only caveat being that the
body still needs to be intact for this
to work there are no downsides to this
and the story even demonstrates this
directly in the climax where taro
demonstrates its power by using the
notebook on himself and then having the
eraser bring him back the one shot ends
with the death note being destroyed and
in an interesting foreshadowing of the
manga itself taro and ryuk years later
observing how the death note has become
an urban legend the final page
essentially asking the young readers
what they would do if they had such an
item now considering that the pilot was
again most likely made after the
serialization was fully planned it's
interesting how it seemed to have been
purely built not off advertising the
actual premise of the manga but instead
the idea the idea of a shinigami's
notebook that kills whoever's name is
written inside this is in a way
illustrative of the series as a whole
because what the death note was sold on
was its idea and the conceits that
spawned from it in a jump which was more
or less defined by the three central
manga running within it death note was
the edgy counterculture piece the
outsider that broke all the rules and
because of that warranted attention as
the rule breaker it was in a sense jumps
alternative art but the weird thing is
it's still kind of fit
[Music]
death notes anime has some of the most
killer music in all of anime and what
better way to experience that than with
raycon's everyday earbuds that now look
sound and feel better than ever they're
so light you'd barely even know they
were on your ears these bad boys are
deathly cool and take note of all these
awesome colors i'm rocking the flare
reds and they fit perfectly on my ear
thanks to the optimized gel tips i can
flail around like a madman and they
straight up won't budge the fact it's
got 8 hours of constant play time and a
32 hour battery life means they're
always ready to go whenever i need them
they're super customizable too for
example you can swap between three sound
profiles to really tailor the sound to
your preference you can dial up the
madness with the bass sound use pure
sound to clear vocals on your podcasts
or simply leave it on balanced sound for
a one size fits all approach you can
also pick noise isolation or awareness
mode to decide whether you want to be
totally immersed or keep track of what's
going on around you it's as simple as
holding the left or right ear bud
respectively for three seconds to cycle
through these modes these things have
over fifty thousand five star reviews
thanks to their awesome audio quality
and that comes at half the price of
other premium audio brands you'd be
taking a huge l and not picking these
bad boys up so what are you waiting for
click the link in the description or go
to buy recon dot com forward slash not
mark to get 15 off your recon purchase
[Music]
has stated in multiple interviews that
he never intended death note to be seen
as being about the moral quandary of the
death note itself that the series was
intended first and foremost as a work of
entertainment and this shows itself in
the framing and the structure of the
story even though the entire premise
revolves around light in his accomplices
committing mass murder essentially every
day the manga seems to deliberately do
everything in its power to downplay that
as much as it possibly can outside of a
handful of circumstances where it's used
on scene bodies are purposely almost
never shown in spite of the hundreds
they are inferred to have killed any and
all references to societal ramifications
with light's crimes are kept to a
minimum and instead the series is mostly
situated around long monologues
regarding the meticulous point-by-point
nature to which light and elf perform
their battle of wits tonally the manga
is surprisingly light given the subject
with persistent use of comic relief
designed to power its narrative nearly
every scene light is in ryuk misa or
matsuda will say or do something dumb
and the gag will be that light as the
straight man barely responding to it
multiple times the series will do a
sudden tonal shift to have stuff like
light and l bonding over a very intense
game of tennis or have matsuta go
through a comedy of errors as he tries
not to be killed by the otsuba group
misa despite being a mass murderer
herself is never treated as anything
more than light's perky female sidekick
and her flippancy under which she
commits her crimes is never really
stressed even light's trademark grin
used often as a mark of tension is used
multiple times as a gag where he wears
it where it is inappropriate as if even
that part is just for the fun of it and
i stress all of this because
demystifying death note as this mature
philosophy piece which it most
definitely is not exposes what its
actual core appeal is the back and forth
of light and l with ryuk a purely
passive observer who serves primarily as
a source of exposition and to give light
someone to talk to light and l are the
only characters of significance with an
active role in the narrative each
scenario the manga sets up in part one
is designed around exploring the angles
in which l sets up traps for light to
fall into all the while light attempts
to get out of them with each minute
detail given attention and dissection as
a possible opening a really good example
of this comes in chapter 16 and 17 when
l has light's room bugged in order to
monitor him on a base this is a really
interesting scenario because elle has
put light into a deadlock either he'll
be exposed using the death note or he'll
be indirectly exposed when the kira
killing start declining while he's under
surveillance the manga is aware of this
and thus the intrigue comes in watching
how light combats it first by laying out
how he figures out that he's being
monitored at all and his counter-attacks
of having ryuk locate and remove the
cameras then laying out each calculated
action he takes to ensure he can
continue his murders without being seen
and safely disposes of the evidence
however the manga crucially does not
give light a complete victory as his
cover strategy still crucially leads to
an aberration in kira's murders that
increases l's focus on light this in
turn leads l to enroll at lights
university completely shifting their
dynamic while progressing the story to
its next stage this kind of interplay
demonstrates what part one is all about
it is a hyper-stylized reinvention of
the classical homes vs moriarty scenario
the mythologized battle between the
eccentric genius detective and the
criminal mastermind with the added twist
of moriarty as the main pov character
elle's character consequently is
designed as the perfect opposite to
light his unkempt appearance unnatural
posture and cam demeanor all contrast
against what defines light soichiro and
misa the most important characters in
part 1 besides the main duo accentuate
this suichiro as a watson provides an
added conflict in how he is both
directly aiding l yet also refusing to
believe light as the culprit while misa
upon her introduction provides light his
mara a loyal accomplice who while not an
intellectual fighter provides a direct
actor who gives moriarty slash light a
host of actions not possible as a lone
actor and framing all of this is the
series final essential element the rules
concluding nearly every chapter is a
relaying of the various rules with which
the death note shinigami and associate
elements function under and how they
work the notebook kills by writing
someone's true name while picturing
their face unless specified the cause of
death will be a heart attack initiated 6
minutes and 40 seconds after the name is
written all that's needed is not the
notebook but the paper within and so on
these rules go extremely in depth laying
out numerous theoreticals and the vast
majority don't factor into the story at
all but all of them go aways in
establishing something important what is
and isn't possible for light and other
characters to do even if something is
seemingly irrelevant the fact that it is
a possibility is something which the
reader is made to consider light even
exploits the importance of this mechanic
by hinging a crucial tactic on forging
rules essentially invoking the later
ellery queen problem to grant himself an
airtight alibi and that is death note's
appeal in a nutshell the point in which
the mind games go so far to where even
the in-story mechanics are being
exploited as tactics this kind of back
and forth built into part one structure
takes on a really interesting turn in
the latter half while light loses his
memory and the story switches to a more
traditional jump narrative where he and
l team up this is generally speaking
viewed as a weaker part of the story as
the mind battles take a back seat and
the story kind of drags its feet through
20 chapters filled with repetitive
scenes of the same generic businessmen
talking about the same topics ad nauseam
but what makes it work is in how the
conflict creates a fascinating new
dimension to the core dynamic of light
and l through which the two characters
together exchange theories and try to
deduce just who exactly the new kira is
the reader gets a far better idea of
both what makes the two so similar and
yet so different the weight for the core
conflict to resume is something which is
actually made a focal aspect of the plot
exploiting the reader's curiosity as to
when and how that will happen and it's
when that moment is reached that gears
shift and we have to re-examine the
series from an entirely different angle
by far the most polarizing critical
assessment of death note is a simple one
was the latter half of the story even
necessary it is hard to argue against
the fact that the latter half of the
manga which i'll now call part 2 for
brevity is decidedly unpopular not only
does the 2006 anime substantially power
it down to 12 episodes in spite of
adapting the only slightly longer part 1
in 25 but both the live-action films and
j-dramas substantially alter the
narrative so to end the series with part
1 working in plot aspects of part 2 but
crucially ending the series so that it
concludes with light and l's final fight
ask anyone on any anime discussion
platform out there and they will say
part two was a mistake a failure of
design and all kinds of other negative
statements that overall color how the
story is viewed today there is overall a
lot to unpack about what does and does
not work and what exactly what is there
is supposed to mean so let's dig into
that by first addressing the common
criticisms at play firstly by far the
key central complaint towards part one
is an obvious one that the story
continues after elle's death not only is
el himself the most popular character in
the series as one look at my anime list
will tell you but the very core appeal i
talked about is something which cannot
function if either light or l is dead
this would naturally suggest the story's
combination to be at this point but
instead the story goes against this and
continues on with a character who while
crucially not actually a copy of l still
greatly resembles him in demeanor all
the while sporting a design which is
essentially a palette swap tellingly in
regards to this attachment to l is in
how both live action adaptations have
him ultimately be victorious over light
albeit at the cost of his own life this
i think stems from a misunderstanding on
the narrative purpose of elle's death
and also how it works as a thematic
undercurrent for the larger story as a
whole in killing off l oba not only
opens up the narrative into a scenario
where light has won but divorces the
conflict away from l the person and
instead to l the idea nir despite his
similarities 2l is pointedly not l in
many ways he is far more emotionally
calm and displays a philosophical
understanding far larger than what his
predecessor ever displayed and that
emotional disconnection he displays
allows the conflict to shift away from a
two-man conflict to something more
universal in scope i'll get into this
more later but for now i just want to
say in order for the story oba and obata
were telling to work light needed to
beat l nothing more nothing less
another complaint i see a lot of the
series is that the loss of l causes the
series to no longer have anyone for the
reader to root for light and his
accomplices are monsters bello is an
immoral terrorist and criminal and near
while not terribly different from elm
morally is too much of a passive
stuck-up kid to really enjoy following
by consequence the story becomes
draining to follow as there is no one to
connect with essentially giving into the
nihilism underpinning the story as a
whole this too is something i think is
wrong while they may not be the primary
drivers of the main narrative the
japanese task force is given
substantially more focus as characters
throughout the second part and with this
focus comes a crucial amount of
emotional grounding that was just absent
entirely from part one izawa who in the
first half of the series was largely a
background character notably takes a
major role as one of the main pov
characters as we see him slowly accept
who light truly is and watching the
feelings of these ordinary men reacting
to an ever deteriorating situation
losing their collective mentor and then
slowly realizing what they'd been
fighting for was in large a lie is
seriously compelling stuff that
contextualizes the narrative through to
its closing moments and i'm honestly
surprised it's not talked about more but
indeed these points do frame the
difference in part 2 which makes it both
so polarizing and at the same time
fascinating to discuss while part 1 was
centered purely on the deadlock of light
and l part 2 takes a far broader
approach touching on the global idea of
kira and his worship the ideals of
fixing society which light's motives are
built around and overall constructing a
complex interconnected web of ideas
which together all build to a singular
point where light's world view is
succinctly rejected rather than
designing the narrative around the
singular point of two characters
fighting oppa instead switches to the
arguably high route of positioning the
story about light's eventual thematic
and literal defeat and that is if
anything a far more interesting story
than el defeats light could ever be
unfortunately while the ideas in play
are not bad the actual handling in story
demonstrates a number of fundamental
problems in the design that causes the
manga to fumble the execution by far the
biggest problem part 2 struggles with is
in its structure while i wouldn't
exactly call the series rushed each
major conflict is resolved more or less
at the same speed as beforehand and
there's rarely a plot point that feels
like it should have been delved into
more the sheer breakneck speed at which
story elements and ideas are introduced
discussed and resolved becomes almost
dizzying only a few chapters after l
dies the story shifts into full gear to
have mellow kidnapped light's little
sister in the process setting off a
plotline in america with a vastly more
dramatic scope than anything in the
series however this ends almost just as
quickly with mellow being written out of
the story almost entirely and the manga
is forced to pivot into both nears
plotting against light and introducing
mikami and takada as light's new
accomplices however since nir cannot
directly go against light until it's
time for the climax the only thing the
manga can do is wander around through
subplots until that point and then it
suddenly remembers mello is still alive
and hauls itself to kill him and takada
off in the span of a single chapter it's
a christmas miracle an event which comes
incredibly abruptly in spite of being
what a major amount of the finale is
built upon and this is essentially the
core issue underpinning part two because
the only logical story direction oba has
is to have near defeat light the entire
narrative until that point is just
delaying the inevitable and consequently
the story is left over complicating
itself to compensate chapters are
routinely interrupted by lengthy
monologues designed to recap information
and it becomes often difficult to
remember who knows what not helped also
by how often the series will reveal that
what characters thought they knew was
just false information while individual
subplots such as kira's global warship
or izawa becoming near's inside men on
the task force are interesting as well
as narratively and thematically relevant
the way these storylines pivot between
one another never really feels cohesive
and there's a lot of space where it
feels like the story could have used its
time better probably the biggest victim
of this kind of narrative crunch is near
unfortunately while the complaint about
him being a carbon copy of l is
inaccurate the lack of any real
breathing room combined with how passive
a character he is means that his role
for much of part 2 is largely relegated
to just occasional cutaways which seem
to exist mainly to remind the reader
that he even exists his relationship
with light lacks the personal edge that
made elle so compelling and his tactical
maneuvers are mostly just in recapping
things the readers already know while
again the point still sees the
engagement suffer because of it
conversely light's role is dramatically
reduced as the shift in focus means he's
rarely put in the actual conflict until
the end up until the climax light in
part 2 is a bit of a cipher as the fact
that he's already effectively won means
there's nowhere for him to go until he's
beat he doesn't really affect near or
mellow as much as they vaguely affect
him and his relationships with his
accomplices despite them being what the
climax in part hinges on is crucially
underdeveloped to where it's not quite
clear what he thought of mikami even by
the end and that's the thing while part
2 tries to expand the scope to a
thematic ideology it consistently is
unable to juggle the way that entails
ideas like kira's worldwide influence
and worship are left feeling unexplored
and underdeveloped characters like
mikami feel forced in without proper
build up or payoff and there is overall
a dragging pace while the shift outside
the two-man battle formula is
commendable it comes at the cost of the
thrilling mind games which part one
enjoyed and is overall in layman's terms
a bit of a drag which makes it all the
more impressive then that despite the
myriad of flaws the second half suffers
from the climax is genuinely gold even
though it is effectively just seven
chapters of the remaining characters
standing in a dark abandoned warehouse
and talking the series finale is easily
the tensest most dramatic cohesive
section of the entire narrative
skillfully managing to weave a proper
culmination to every idea that had ran
through the story and given greater
purpose to the previous 20 odd chapters
which all existed to set this up the
climax especially serves to demonstrate
full purpose to near as his calculated
approach allows the finale to carry
itself without any unneeded actions or
snapbacks and watching him refute light
so simply is in a sense delightful
[Laughter]
while it's not perfect i can't really
imagine a better way for death note to
end if the overall story was about
light's crusade against evil then what
the story needed to end on is this not a
grand battle with the fate of justice on
the line but on a question being
answered the true thematic conclusion to
the tale
which finally brings us to the ending
and the meaning of this story
without question the biggest and most
persistent misconception about death
note is what exactly it's about most
sources youtube reviewers geek culture
news sites and just random people on
social media present this about the idea
of justice and how the series is reliant
on the question on if light's crusade is
right light is a mass murderer yet in
killing criminals he is arguably doing
the right thing by punishing evil as
light himself states in being presented
with a god which punishes all evil
people are made to become kinder and war
premeditated murder and organized crime
are all but eradicated crucially what
these arguments do is press forward a
single straightforward claim that the
series provides no true answer to the
core dilemma if light was truly right to
perform his crusade or if ellen near
were right to have him stopped what is
justice is up for the reader to
ultimately decide only problem though
there is an answer and it's pretty
plainly that light is wrong from the
very start of the manga light's murder
spree as kira is never shown as anything
other than a negative never once in the
series are we ever shown positive
results from his murders indeed it's
explicitly noted that crime goes past
the rate it was before kira became a
thing after the murders temporarily go
away besides misa who is not meant to be
seen as sympathetic in the slightest no
one is ever shown being benefited from
light's crimes and the only one who
suggests such matsuda is repeatedly
called out for it by other characters
moreover the idea that light is anything
but a villain is laughable even though
light sincerely does believe he is doing
the right thing his characterization is
shown to be petty unhinged and
remorseless insofar as the innocent
lives he takes and he displays an
extraordinary absence of sympathetic and
humanizing traits never once does the
manga or creator ever portray him as a
fallen hero all it does is refer to him
as childish and quote pure this is
important and indeed he can't be as
everything he does by the end is stuff
he was planning to do from the start
even when he dies the reader isn't
invited to morton but just think about
the sort of person he was this is all
clinched in the most thematically
crucial moment of the entire series when
after an extended six page rant
expressing all of his motives and world
view light's entire ideology is
destroyed when near bluntly tells him
that as he cannot dictate what is
objectively right or wrong kira is
therefore nothing more than a murderer
seeing as ellen near openly state they
are not fighting kira for the reason of
justice but respectively personal
interest and pride as the world's
greatest detectives and regarding near a
desire to finish what else started this
actually gives a different message
entirely that justice does not exist as
an objective concept but only what one
perceives in their own mind hence
forcing that justice onto the world as a
god is wrong not because of ethics but
due to that very contradiction itself
where this gets really interesting
though is when one discusses the anime
and specifically how it impacts the
viewer's interpretation of light i've
been kind of avoiding talking about the
tetsuro araki directed anime thus far
primarily because i think the manga is
more valuable as a source text but a lot
of the misunderstandings the series has
are rooted in iraqi's directorial
choices as an adaptation most crucially
to this is the way it frames light's
character and the story through homages
and invocations of judeo-christian art
literally using a direct comparison to
michelangelo's the creation of adam in
the op to depict light receiving the
death note from ryuk a presentational
idea which doesn't even make sense when
you break it down the soundtrack is
persistently laced with booming chants
associated with christian imagery most
often used when light's plans are in
play whereas the manga is mostly told in
plain light and staging the anime adds a
heavy color gradient which stresses the
apocalyptic atmosphere rather than
simply presenting a shot of him noticing
the notebook light's discovery is framed
with heavy shadows that show the
darkness symbolically pulling him in
when light declares his desire to become
the god of the new world while the manga
shows a shot of his eyes to express his
conviction the anime instead frames it
against the setting sun this very act
displaying a defiance of the heavens
themselves light in the anime is at once
lucifer and the corrupted first man
tempted by the evil apple of
enlightenment everything about the
adaptation is designed to reinforce this
interpretation in spite of how utterly
against the manga it is light's inner
monologue which demonstrates his
willingness to kill anyone even his own
little sister is heavily cut down upon
while the anime pays way more focus on
the grandeur of his killing spree and
ideological fight with l notably the
anime cuts out the majority of light's
motive rent in the climax outlining his
entire world view just having him argue
that he's made the world better and thus
did what no one else could all of this
together goes to create a very different
character one who was not a twisted
distortion of japanese youth but instead
some sort of dark messiah who twists the
world to his whim now while some of
these changes are likely just the
adaptation itself at play i mean part
two of the anime is heavily trimmed down
for the manga and light's persistent
thoughts would have worked quite poorly
in an active visual medium but what
cannot be viewed as anything but an
intentional change comes in the anime's
ending and this is where things get
irritating for the most part the manga
and the anime have the same events play
out after light's final gambit to kill
nir the task force and the spk via
mikami is foiled and light has his
secret identity exposed light attempts
to kill near via the spare notebook
piece in his watch is gunned down by
matsuda and then slowly bleeds out
before ryuk puts him out of his misery
with the death note in the manga this is
done to make light look as pathetic as
humanly possible writhing around in pain
as he begs for someone to help him and
kill everyone else before culminating in
him desperately pleading repeatedly how
he doesn't want to die as the futility
of his existence becomes apparent
ryuk then writes his name in the death
note and light's body drops lifeless to
the ground the conclusion of light
yagami in the manga is a two-page spread
of his dazed corpse as unsightly as the
countless people he killed
in the anime however light somehow
manages to run away from the task force
after being shot despite the obvious
fact that he should effectively be
immobile at this point and we are also
treated to a slow montage of light's
life slowly flashing before his eyes
while sad music is playing there is no
desperate pleading for his enemies to
die or his own survival and instead
light's final moments are him quietly
passing away on a staircase with just
ryuk there to comfort him and say they
had a fun time together as the anime
erases the manga's epilogue this is
essentially the note the series closes
on framing it around lights tragic rise
and fall from grace an idea which is
pretty much as far away from the manga
as you could possibly get in other words
according to this light tried to do the
right thing and he should be mourned for
in spite of the horrible crimes he
committed along the way
this kind of reinterpretation and
attempt to justify a misconception about
the text as the actual truth continues
into all other adaptations of the story
essentially piling on top of each other
this idea that falls apart the moment
you actually read the original text the
live-action films while they have to
have light's crimes escalate much
quicker as a way of moving the plot
along it gives his motives and mises
backstory far more focused than the
actual source material ever did and thus
makes him substantially more sympathetic
as characters including giving light a
far more humanizing death scene than the
one he gets in either the manga or the
anime the j-drama discards light's most
defining character trait his immense
intelligence and ego in favor of him
being an ordinary university student who
does give a [ __ ] about his family and
misa and is shown saving people as kira
the netflix adaptation however goes the
whole nine yards
and transforms him into the
stereotypical bullied outcast kid who
just wants to make the world better and
is horrified by the idea of killing
innocent people who are in his way with
by the way all of the original negative
traits lighthead backported into this
version of misa which is just another
classic netflix girl bossification of a
character which in attempting to fix a
quote problem with the source material
instead turns the character into a
rapidly misogynistic stereotype now my
point with listing these changes isn't
to illustrate all the ways adaptations
try to make light more sympathetic but
to instead display a consistent pattern
in how death notes myriad of adaptations
approach the source material light's
numerous villainous traits his readiness
to murder innocent people who get in his
way his complete lack or care for anyone
but himself and his utter refusal to see
anything he does as morally
reprehensible all openly get in the way
of what most people imagine death note
to be about and thus adaptations seek to
rectify this by changing the story to
suit this desire it's not as much about
changing the story to the adaptation's
own vision per se but instead correcting
the original narrative to what they
think it should be that or they're
trying to make the story about
lightning's epic bromance which they do
quite a lot mind you the really ironic
thing here though is that for all of the
posturing about biblical imagery and
right and wrong the adaptations do none
of them actually seem to properly
understand what the original manga is
about
that being essentially
a societal critique
in the early 1990s japan went through
something of a societal collapse after
an entire decade of rapid financial
growth sudden widespread policy changes
in 1989 led to a bubble burst and
nationwide recession that would last the
next 20 years the group perhaps hit
hardest by this was the quote lost
generation the japanese youth who after
spending their entire lives being
extensively pressured to study their
asses off get into high quality
universities and from there inherit the
world from their parents entered the
workforce to instead find a world with
no jobs a collapsed marketplace and an
older generation which seemed only
interested in throwing their own
problems onto others many many texts
have been written about the influence of
this generational disillusionment and
how it permeated so much of the iron
culture developed after that bubble
burst but what matters here is a single
terrible event
in march of 1995 a series of coordinated
attacks were carried out across the
tokyo subway system wherein packages of
siren gas wrapped in newspaper were
carefully placed inside the trains
during rush hour and then punctured by
umbrellas as the culprits fled the scene
the attack in total killed 13 people and
seriously injured a thousand more with
it being only sheer luck the number
wasn't higher the event itself ended up
sending all of japanese society into a
panic in the wake of the incident the
organization that had carried out such a
large-scale event was identified to have
been a controversial religious group
based near mount fuji one which had been
growing ever since that very bubble
burst they were an organization that
society would describe as nothing but
evil they would make members demonstrate
loyalty by killing friends and family
they killed anyone who sought to
criticize or investigate them and kill
their loved ones alongside them they
would take part in depraved drug-fueled
parties designed to free their souls
their charismatic leader was a man who
spoke of the coming apocalypse and world
war iii stockpiling weapons and
developing bioterrorism plots in secret
their goal was to overthrow the japanese
government and bring about a war only
they as the chosen few would survive
going so far as to mail a bomb to the
governor of tokyo and for the crimes
they committed their highest ranking
members were all sentenced to death the
organization's name
was om shinrikyo
what made am shinrikyo's crimes so
important to japanese society wasn't the
severity or horror of what they had done
japan had over the last 15 years seen
many terrible crimes that struck at the
darkness of the human heart the
devastating yamaichi yakuza war the
prolonged 46-day murder of junko furuta
the depraved child killings of the otaku
murderer all these crimes were terrible
but they were still the practices of
those outside organized crimes social
outcasts mysterious villains they were
all people society didn't have to
recognize people they could easily
reject om shinrikyo however was
different its membership primarily
consisted of young people fresh out of
high quality universities the kinds
which society put its faith in to
continue where the prior generation
would leave off yet the disillusionment
of an entire generation instead made
these people decide to become part of a
collective of monsters their leader and
founder shoko asahara was a man whose
doctrine positioned him as the
reincarnation of both buddha and christ
seeking to take upon himself all of the
world's sins and he carried out all of
his crimes believing he was bringing
about salvation for the world at large
no matter the monstrousness of their
actions that kind of conviction was
certainly something a lost generation
could really rally behind and was even
willing to enact whatever terrible acts
were required of them if it wasn't
obvious
this is what light is meant to represent
as a character not lucifer but a
representation of the kind of inherent
bitterness and disillusionment which
would drive someone who'd be considered
the future of society to become a mass
murderer as he himself states in the
finale light's desire to become a quote
god comes not from a position of
arrogance or lust for power but from his
own belief that someone had to take up
the role and make the world right what
light wanted was for people to come to
live with kira as a new normality a
persistent reminder that evil will bring
with it a divine punishment and thus
everyone who strays from that path of
good will be met with righteous fury
this is demonstrative in the kinds of
people like targets not criminals in a
broad sense but people who act in a
purposeful calculated manner to harm
others and worsen society he would even
go as far as to object to mikabi killing
ex-convicts who'd atoned for their sins
it is not a coincidence then that all of
the characters who displayed sympathy
with kira's actions misa matsuda takeda
and mikami all belong to the same young
generation light himself spawned from he
is what they and all of youth want to
inherit a world where a savior is truly
making things better and of course light
is wrong as near says in a world where
objective good and evil don't exist all
his crimes are in the end is the work of
a murderer not a savior light's refusal
to understand the weight of his own
humanity his own purity that leads him
to think he can actually become such an
individual and that he would make the
world better is why he even used the
death note to begin with tellingly what
causes light's own downfall is in mikami
his own desire for people to understand
his worldview which only ends up working
against him as mikami ends up ruining
everything because of his eagerness to
aid kira's world and when pushed into a
corner light is left with no option but
to deny mikami as a person and when
light himself is left begging for
someone to save him bikini denies him
right back his delusion shattered by the
truth of who his god really turned out
to be making him then realize that light
ruined his life and so in a sense
light's true death comes not from being
outwitted or as hubris but from his own
ideology being proven as wrong and that
true defeat comes not from l or near it
comes from the one person to represent
everything
matsuda
since his introduction at the start of
this series matsuda's role has been that
of the comic relief rarely does a scene
with him in focus past where he's not
made the idiot with characters shouting
matsuda you idiot becoming a running gag
in the story he's treated as a joke
humiliated nearly killed a number of
times and overall in general disregarded
this makes it all the more shocking and
important however when it ends up being
matsuda who puts down light for good
riddlium full of holes as light barks
orders at him to kill nir and the task
force even as light tries to convince
him to stop matsuda does it and has to
be physically pulled away by the rest of
the task force before he kills light
outright why this scene is so important
is simple and yet answers everything
death note has been about unlike elle
and near's teammates who staunchly agree
in kieran needing to be stopped matsuda
stands squarely in a gray area as the
young rookie police detective who got in
on family connections he understands
that kira is a mass murderer but can't
help but sympathize with him as someone
trying to make the world a better place
while izawa in part 2 represents how an
older reader might feel consistently
horrified at the lengths light is going
to to ensure his perfect world becomes a
reality matsuda represents the younger
reader who suffers from that same
disillusionment as light did and even
knowing it is wrong has a part of
themselves that wants it to be right in
having matsuda reject light so
thoroughly however oba communicates
effectively what he wants us as readers
to think just as om were not a divine
society which would survive armageddon
but a psychotic terrorist cult light is
not a god delivering humanity on the
right path but an insane serial killer
enforcing his beliefs onto others
matsuda doesn't have an unavenged family
childhood bullying complex or lights
quote manhood but the compulsion for a
better world and light's world is one
where that isn't the truth because no
one understood life because the vague
idea of kira is what some were
frightened of some sought to exploit
some idealize but none truly could see
kira is death kira is god kira is
salvation kira is all of those things
because it is an idea which light yagami
embodies and lisa amane kiyomi takada
and terumikami worship but that idea is
a child's understanding of those things
because light is too idealistic to
understand that murder in the name of
justice is still murder death note might
not be a story of two ideals fighting
but it is a story of how an idealist's
view of justice is wrong light dies not
out of hubris but because he ultimately
cannot understand that anyone would
truly see him as wrong the final reveal
of the series given in the very last
rule page is that there is no such thing
as the afterlife in a world of shinigami
enacting death upon all the entire world
itself exists in a state of near cosmic
nihilism where one's very soul ceases to
be the moment they die light knew this
from the start of his journey but when
faced with the reality he devolved into
fear his pitiful begging reinforcing his
own hollowness as he dies miserable and
terrified light yagami kira has been
defeated his world destroyed his
personal legacy all but erased he exists
as a cautionary tale at best and a cruel
joke at first justice doesn't exist life
doesn't exist and a better world
doesn't exist so the question comes
what then
the answer comes in the manga's epilogue
notably excluded from the anime it
depicts a world one year after light's
death where in spite of no one outside
of near's team and the task force
knowing the truth behind light's crimes
the absence of kira has seen the world
revert back to the way it used to be
matsuda still emotionally scared from
the climax discusses a theory he has on
it and the possibility of near being
himself a far more dubious character
than once believed as pointed out this
isn't coming from a place of logic or
truth but because he wanted to believe
that light regardless of his crimes was
someone he still wanted to understand
and believe in with the world having
reverted back in the wake of kira's
death can anything of what they did be
considered right eide however tells him
that he has no doubt they were right
because it doesn't matter if near was
any more righteous than light was all
that matters is that they are alive
right now there is no justice in this
world but life still exists so shouldn't
that be enough
well far from perfect death notes
imperfections in many ways highlights
just how powerful a work it really is it
is a story which in its conclusion tears
apart every ideal it at one point
presented expressly proving the futility
in trying to understand the conflict as
no different than someone who just
wanted something they wanted inside
themselves to be true we all wish for a
savior we all wish for someone who can
write the world's ills our desire for
that delusion is disgusting perhaps even
disturbing and someone who would take
that role on is certainly a madman but
it is nevertheless human and as life
goes on so too does this delusion our
prayers for a better world one which we
live in to the very
end
thanks for watching
[Music]
you